and I I am so broken by it Eddie I'm I'm
waking up at 3 o'clock in the morning
and I'm praying for Palestinian children
and I and I start crying and I I can't
look at the I can't look at the videos I
I I start I start sobbing I break down I
cry I I it is disturbing me so
much I've never had anything in my life
disturb me so much as what's happening
to the Palestinian people in the last
several weeks it Grieves me it troubles
me asalam Alum greetings of Peace thank
you guys for tuning in get ready
everyone my next guest is none other
than Senior Pastor Rick WS from the
flowing streams Church Pastor Rick as
also his own news TV show many of you
have been sharing his intriguing
insightful videos with me now before we
bring Pastor Rick out and make history
here for those that don't know who he is
let's go ahead and play this video that
went viral with Pastor Rick sharing some
very important history when the
Islamic uh Warrior saladan conquered the
Crusaders and took control of Jerusalem
all right he entered into an agreement
that that that the Muslims would protect
the Christian
churches and so he appointed two
Muslim families both of these families
had been in Jerusalem for uh you know
close to A Thousand Years and each
generation has passed down the key the
key right the the physical key Mr um
Judah said that the key he presently has
is 800 years old it's incredible he had
another key but it
broke this is Muslim I mean AD Judah is
a Muslim and he said it's a it's a great
honor for a Muslim to hold the key to
the Church of the Holy sea which is the
most important Church in
Christendom that's not disrespect that's
we don't hear this in America we don't
hear because what what we have been told
is Christians Christian Americans and
you know you you should hate Muslims you
should kill Muslims because they they're
going to tear down all the churches and
and and uh you know basically just rans
sack them and everything else but here
we have two families that for nearly a
thousand years have actually been
watching over yes that's right so who
planted into our minds here in America
that we should hate and kill Muslims who
planted that thought in our head because
it it came into our society after 9/11
Jews Christians and Muslims have lived
together for centuries they were buying
and selling they were were trading they
were doing business together they were
building houses next door to each other
for centuries and it didn't change
until I love you you're doing when I was
ready to talk about it I would I was
explaining how much respect I have for
the faith of
Islam show the de
show
Pastor Rick how are you I'm doing great
Eddie that was an old video where did
you where did you find it people have
been you got a lot of Muslim fans you
got a lot a lot of Muslims been sharing
your videos with me I've been sharing it
also and I'm I'm very honored to have
you on the program thank you you know
when I I I had the pleasure of visiting
Jordan four times last year uhhuh and uh
I I would be walking down the streets of
various CI cities not just of mine in
other cities and people would come up to
me often they didn't know my name they
just would say I know you you're the
you're the you're the American preacher
or you're the the news sometimes they
called me the newsman and this happened
a lot sometimes in dinner I was in a
restaurant in am man and a a gentleman
came over uh he didn't speak English uh
he uh addressed me
um wanted to know if he could speak I
had an an interpreter with me and he
told me that he was watching um our show
every day because it was being
translated into Arabic and so there are
a lot of a lot of people who are
translating our videos into Arabic we
don't even know about it it's just
circulating around the Arab world so
we're very honored very humbled and it's
it's nice to know that we have friends
throughout the Arab world absolutely
absolutely so let's start off with this
um in in this video you guys mentioned
this um important history and it's
really nice seeing it coming from
someone such as yourself and towards the
end you said who planted that in our
heads to to hate to Hate Muslims after
you just went over this Rich important
history that if anybody any Christian
that sees that you know this would you
would believe it will soften your heart
you know and and bring the hearts
together rather than apart this huge
division that's happening
well I know the answer and and the
answer is uh Zionist I did not say Jews
I said
Zionist because Eddie uh up
until I would say until September 11
2001 I had I had never had a a negative
thought about Muslims or Arabs and I
also didn't have any negative thoughts
about Jews
I I grew up in a small uh rural
community uh you know this is I I'm I'm
70 years old so this is back you know in
the 50s 60s 7s and to this day I can
remember all of the Jewish
businessmen in in my community I know
the retailers the doctor everybody the
Jeweler and we were all
friends
when 911
came the the American news media was
weaponized and it came at us from every
direction that Muslims had invaded
America and they were going to kill
us and the American people were very
afraid we were afraid if we met a Muslim
on the street they might bring out pull
out a knife and try to chop off our head
and this came at us from every
direction the American people had never
had these thoughts
ever I don't recall ever having these
kind of thoughts but after 911 it was it
was you could tell there was
a the propaganda had had already been
formulated had been designed and it was
simply being
implemented and it was it it came from
every direction tell television the news
um it got into the movies and the
Hollywood movies and then it got into
the
churches and the churches were told
Beware of the Muslims they're coming
they're coming to America to kill the
Christians you know I'm I'm I'm sad to
tell you I'm I I I I I I'm embarrassed
to tell you that for a couple years I
believe
it because I didn't know what was
happening to my
country it took me it took me a couple
years to figure
out the game
plan and to figure out that we had been
we had been told a lie and there was a
massive propaganda campaign
underway and that um what happened on
9/11 was not the the official narrative
was not
true and it was it was shocking to me it
was shocking that I had
to uh I had to process a lot of stuff
about hap what was happening in my
country and I had my mind had to process
that I had been fed disinformation lies
propaganda somebody was trying to make
me and everybody else in my country
believe something about other people
that wasn't true
and then I figured it
out and and and then after I figured it
out they came after
me okay wow and it wasn't the Muslims it
wasn't the Muslims who were coming after
me I get it yeah tell me this I I I've
heard you once reference um the
scoffield Bible and you talk about con
if it was a while ago if you can um help
me Connect the Dots here
just give us a brief history like you
you were mentioning if I remember
correctly something about the scoffield
Bible and a certain theology or yes that
was being pushed uh that from there it
kicked off what today uh we have from
the Christians who got um fed this into
the Christian Zionism in this move is
that correct yes so you you have to go
back um I mean I can take the I can take
the story back
in into the 1700s but where it really
started to come together was the the
early 1800s in the 1830s there was a man
in Ireland and his name was John Nelson
Darby and he was a a young Anglican
Church of England well Church of Ireland
an
Anglican uh priest and he became
dissatis if IED with the church of
Ireland and he began holding his own
meetings and eventually he moved to
England and um he was in a town called
Plymouth and his meetings uh the people
who came to his meetings they got the
name the Plymouth Brethren the Plymouth
Brothers
okay well anyhow Mr
Derby uh it's not so much that he venant
things but
he it was like he was
collecting strange religious
doctrines that were out on the far far
far edge of the Christian church
that few Christian leaders took them
seriously or even heard of them they
were very strange extreme
ideas but he kind of picked them up like
he was putting flowers in a basket and
then he sewed them together and he made
a
Theology and I call it Darby ISM uh it's
um
dispensationalism I have a name for it
dipy ISM and it's
dppz dispensational premillennial
pre-tribulation
Zionism and um he came he created this
Theology and it really didn't go
anywhere
he eventually died in the in the uh
around 1880s something and never really
made any success with his little
movement it's interesting Eddie I I have
if you see I have a lot of books here
these are real books the these are not
props I have about I don't know
somewhere between seven and 10,000
books and I buy mostly old
books and Eddie when you get when you go
back you don't really have to go too far
with I'm talking about Christian books
Christian theology books you don't have
to go back too far and Zionism
disappears it's not
there if you had gone to
seminaries at a certain time in America
you never heard of
Zionism somehow it got into the
seminaries in the Bible colleges
so Mr Darby died excuse excuse me he
died he wasn't
famous but a man named Cyrus scoffield a
man named Cy Scofield came around and he
was a a con man he was a flimflam
man um you know what a flimflam man is
uh these are terms he was a a hustler he
he cheated people out of
money like a charlatan a charlatan and
he and he went to jail this is back in
the 18 unds uh he was a liar a cheat
this is Scofield this is scoffield yes
sir this was Cyrus scoffield M Mr
scoffield was a less than honorable
man and he did go to jail for cheating
people out of
money when he got out of jail again this
would this would have been around the
1880s when he got out of
jail he was introduced to a preacher in
St Louis Missouri who knew John Nelson
Derby and somehow Mr scoffield instantly
became a Christian
preacher he just got out of
jail and suddenly he's an expert on the
end of the
world and he started traveling around as
a Christian Bible expert um he took on
the title do
scoffield a doctor of divinity he never
went to college he never went to
Seminary he didn't have any
degrees he was a
liar and on the front page of the
scoffield Bible it says Dr Cyrus
scoffield and that was a
lie
well he came up with this idea of taking
John Nelson Derby's
Doctrine and putting it in the Christian
Bible so I have a Bible here okay this
is not a scofi Bible I've got a Scofield
bible here somewhere so he they were put
in as footnotes at the bottom of the
page explaining each
scripture so a person reading the
scripture would look down at the
footnotes and there would be an
explanation of what that
means he took John Nelson Darby's ideas
and put them in in the Bible wow all
right so now wait to hear this scoffield
didn't have any money he was always
broke
somehow
a he was given a membership in the Lotus
Club of New York which was a high
society private club of very famous
people he couldn't afford the
membership the membership was more than
his
salary you had to be invited you had to
be sponsored the man who brought him
into the
club
was a a powerful lawyer in New York City
who
was either the president or the vice
president of the American Zionist
organization wow okay
it's starting to come together now yes
and that
lawyer that lawyer is the man who wrote
the
law that was passed in
1913 that gave us the Federal Reserve
Banking
Act the same
lawyer so this this lawyer arranged for
Mr scoffield to travel to England and he
got a meeting with the executives of
Oxford publishing at Oxford University
and Mr scoffield came back to America
with a contract from Oxford publishing
and an advance
money then another gentleman came on the
scene his name was Arno
gabin and he was he
was supposed to be a Christian preacher
but they said he spoke
Yiddish so fluent ly that the Jews of
New York thought he was a
Jew well he came on board as a paid
editor for Mr scoffield but Mr scoffield
really didn't have the money to pay this
guy this this guy named gabin is
actually the man who put all of John
Nelson Darby's ideas in the
Bible then then Oxford published a Bible
over in England and then Oxford gave
away what I was told Oxford gave away 1
million copies of the Bible in the early
1900s to get the Bible into Christian
churches that's
how
scoffield got in got inside the door of
the churches then Christian
denominations Bible colleges seminaries
began
teaching the Darby doctr the Scofield
Doctrine and it was it was written it
was designed by
zionists and it it didn't really have
much it didn't have a lot of of impact
in the 1920s the 30s the 40s the
50s it didn't get a lot of following
until you got to
1970s and there was a book called the
late great planet Earth written by Mr
how Lindsay he's still alive he's almost
a hundred years old and that book sold
40 million
copies and it was it was scoffield ISM
it was Darby ISM it was Zionism packaged
as Christian doctrine what's it saying
what what are what are the key teachings
in there that differentiate it from the
Kim James version or any other Bible
well what they teach hold
on what they teach is that
Jesus is going to come back
twice and that's not in the Bible no
Christians ever believe that but they
teach he's going to come back twice he's
going to come back and remove the
Christians take them to heaven and then
there's going to be seven years of
tribulation of wars and famines and all
kinds of bad things happening and then
um the Antichrist is going to gather his
armies to attack the Jews in
Israel and then Jesus is going to come
back again and save the Jews that's the
doctrine and that's not in the King
James or any other Bible this is
specifically this this was where is this
actually in the scoffield Bible is this
in how how did they interject this and
throw this in line by line the footnotes
at the bottom of the pages of the Bible
and they created this
Zionist doctrine that eventually took
over the Christian churches in America I
see that brings me that brings me now to
uh a next another video that goes into
what you were what we're talking about
and we can continue on after the
audience sees this here in the United
States the Christian Zionist movement
John haggy go down the list of them
Perry Stone Lance wnow Steven Strang at
Charisma you go down the whole list of
Zionist puppets are clapping and
cheering for this atrocity they're
delighted I mean this is just so
incredibly disingenuous on their part
call be peacemakers why aren't they
calling for peace why aren't they
negotiating why aren't they putting
pressure on Israel you have to stop
treating the Palestinians like they're
animals you say you're the children of
God but you treat the Palestinians like
their rats why aren't these Christian
leaders telling the Jewish Zionist this
is ungodly you say you're the chosen
people of God you can't behave like this
I was thinking like wow why aren't any
Christians or any people of God you know
who believe in God coming out and and
then I see you I was like wow this is
very powerful you're just saying some
just common sense you're asking some
common sense questions uh where why
aren't people calling for peace uh and
then in the beginning of this video you
mentioned some key figures are these are
these pastors now who are Christian
zionists that kind of run this movement
well there there there's some of them
the one gentleman John heggy to destroy
the Democracy in this country they
worship death the Jewish
people are are is probably the most
prominent and he is the the founder of a
group called Christians United for
Israel it is a it is a Zionist propag
Anda operation and it's not run by
Christians most of the employees are are
Israeli
zus it's a propaganda operation yeah
John heggy I heard so he's uh but he's
he's a pastor yes in San Antonio
Texas have you ever met him no sir no
does does do you think they do they know
about this what you're talking about
these facts do they know what uh about
this uh when we went into now the scull
field the doctrine are they aware of
what they're doing that this is not in
any yes yes they are aware so so there
there's blatantly lying to their
congregations I'm not going to say
particularly any I won't
I'm let's just say Eddie in general yeah
in general without me naming names yes I
believe that many of the biggest most
influential powerful
Christian zionists in America are
Freemasons at the heart at the heart of
this movement is
Freemasonry you want to know why
why because Freemasonry is built on
Solomon's
Temple they they believe that
Solomon uh they believe that Solomon was
the first Freemason because he he used
masonry to
build this great Temple and um there the
entire concept of Freemasonry is built
around uh a a a character named hyam
abith and and it's it's quite
complicated to get into what the Masons
believe about this man but at the at the
core of it the Masons are
seeking secret knowledge hidden
Forbidden
Knowledge I call it I don't know how you
would describe it as a I call it um
occult demonic
satanic uh it's magic it's it's it's
it's forbidden
it's things that you should not
know things you you have no reason to
know uh evil they are seeking that
knowledge they believe that knowledge
came from
Babylon
and when the Jews were captive in
Babylon I believe that they they learned
the
Babylonian secret
knowledge this was knowledge that that
the
Babylonian um
civilization had
acquired going back to now I don't know
with Muslims we you know we believe that
there was a great flood with Noah and
yes we believe in yes all right so I I
believe that there was
knowledge that was passed down through
generations that was not from God it was
from the evil one and that is the
forbidden knowledge and I believe uh uh
that knowledge was was stored in
Babylon and the Freemasons believe that
that Solomon found he acquired that
knowledge and he buried it it's buried
somewhere beneath the rubble of of
Solomon's
Temple if you believe if you believe the
Jews where was Solomon's Temple they
would say it's it was where the Temple
Mount is now at in Jerusalem the alasco
mosque so all these Christian Zionist
like heggy they want a third Temple for
Israel there is nothing in the Christian
Bible that says that the Jews have to
build a third Temple but they want one
built nothing in the bi nothing in the
Bible to suban nothing nothing it's this
is stuff made up by scoffield and
Darby wow so these are like these now
self they trying to push prophecies
they're trying to make prophecies self
crazy yes yes and now they have now they
have control of US foreign policy to
make their prophecies come true yeah
that so this this this hidden
knowledge they believe is still there
somewhere beneath the Temple
Mount so what's standing in the way the
Temple
Mount they've got to get rid of the
Temple Mount and who's who else do they
have to get rid
of the Muslims who are guarding the
temple
Mountain so they can't build their third
Temple until they get rid of the Muslims
and the Temple
Mount but my belief is this
Temple it's it's a masonic Freemason
Temple I know for a fact through
historical research that that the Jews
have been doing Freemason secret
rituals beneath the Temple mount for
quite some time in the
tunnels this is part of the uh Temple
Institute they openly talk about this
don't they is this connected to the
temple Institute the fact is that every
few days archaeologist in Israel are
digging up uh
memorabilia I I don't know if it's a
temple Institute but I know that um you
know I I know going back in the 1800s
there were explorers there were
archaeologists sent by Great Britain by
financed by the United lods of Great
Britain the the mothership of
Freemasonry yeah they they they it was
called the Palestine exploration fund
and they financed it and they were they
were looking for the the secret
knowledge hidden under the
temple and and one of the first things
that they did was hold a masonic
ritual on under the
temple so
this whole thing is is is based on
masonry and a lot of people are
dying a lot of innocent people are dying
because there are some
radical to me they're insane they're mad
they they've lost their Humanity they
they're willing to kill thousands of
children for this
cause and I I am so broken by it Eddie
I'm I'm waking up at 3:00 in the morning
and I'm praying for Palestinian children
and I and I start crying and I I can't
look at the I can't look at the videos I
I I start I start sobbing I break down I
cry I I it is disturbing me so
much I've never had anything in my life
disturb me so much as what's
happening to the Palestinian people in
the last several weeks it Grieves me it
troubles me I I don't know what to do I
I'm doing everything I can to stop it
I'm doing all that I can do to stop it
God bless you God bless you hopefully we
can do our small part and a waken some
hearts because all it takes is to see
those images to really see that what you
you know what what most people are not
seeing but if they can go and and just
have a look and put themselves in that
situation I mean it's just it's it's
horrifying I'm going to get into uh some
more uh Clips here I want to get your
reaction I don't know if you've heard um
of the pbd
[Music]
podcast
for
I
he starts off by showing uh who's the
governor here he shows him a clip I
don't know if you've seen this when they
have Netanyahu he's pretty much saying
that we pretty much got the Americans in
our pocket you know it's so he shows
this clip and they take off from there
and and he asks a a relevant question so
we'll listen to this question and see
how you would answer this I have a
problem with my allies using me as a
card to abuse that get out of jail card
and then eventually this thing can turn
around and lead into World War III
because World War I 90 million people
died two 60 million people died if the
third one happens at that trajectory
it's 200 million people do you think
Netanyahu is kind of using a get out of
jail card to do what he wants to do and
what he's been wanting to do with
Palestine all these years now look I I
don't think I mean I think you pointed
out how does they have the best security
in the world and yet this is a massive
attack on their civilian population so
my sense is in in Israel is that the
public is very disenchanted with the
government I think they view it as
having been a big problem that this
happened uh and so I think they're now
in a situation where they have to say
okay you know you have this group on the
in the Gaza Strip which by the way is
not occupied territory Israel pulled out
in 2006 what what are your thoughts well
let's start with the fact that uh
um it was the the government of of
Benjamin
Netanyahu that strengthened
Hamas and everybody in Israel knows it
everybody knows that Netanyahu backed
Hamas for
years why he wanted to divide the
Palestinians he did not want fat the
Palestinian Authority to be powerful so
he wanted to split the Palestinians so
he provided funding and support for
Hamas
to build them
up nobody in America will talk about it
but all you have to do is go to the
Israeli newspapers and you can read the
stories about Netanyahu providing
financing to Hamas so now he pretends
that he's been their enemy all along he
hasn't he's using
people Mr net the other gentleman was Mr
Governor Rond Des
santis did you know who that was was
Ronda santis yes the governor of Florida
my my Governor here um have you ever met
him no I I voted for him uh I don't know
if I would vote for him again I wouldn't
vote for him for president now he is he
is such a a he is such a Zionist puppet
that I can't support him anymore he was
a good Governor but I don't want him as
president of United States he he belongs
to the Zionist
Lobby
it's plain and simple they own him name
one person running for president United
States who is not owned by the Zionist
name one
person there's not one person running
for president of the United States who
is not owned by the
Zionist you can't run for president in
this country and be an opponent of
Zionism you can't do
it so
all of this uh again is
propaganda
and the Palestinian people are being
systematically removed
Netanyahu he's got two
options move out all the Palestinians
from Gaza and the West
Bank or kill
them those are his options
MH I I I mentioned you showed that video
um I stood next to Netanyahu in Davos
Switzerland president Trump took me to
Davos twice I went with the White House
I didn't ride in Air Force One with the
president you know I had to get myself
there but I had a White House badge so
you you know you met president Trump I
didn't meet him you know do you do you
know president Trump nope nope I I I've
been I've been to marago several times
I've you know I've been
10 to 15 feet away from him but you know
I I've never met him um but uh the White
House took me to Davos the world
economic Forum twice and I had one
incident where I was just standing uh I
was actually waiting I was actually
waiting on a sandwich and and and I
heard a commotion and the door opened up
and Benjamin Netanyahu came into the
room and stood right beside my left my
left arm I mean I I could have put my
arm around his shoulder I mean his his
security guards were there but I got a
good look in his
eyes and to me they were shark
eyes dead
lifeless I remember coming back telling
people that man I could imagine him
driving a bulldozzer
and if his mother was standing in his
way and he had to do something with that
bulldozer for Zionism he would drive
over top his mother and he would eat a
turkey sandwich while he was doing it
wow that's the coldness I saw in that
Man's
eyes so what is he doing right now he's
he's carrying out
genocide
uh Eddie I don't know if you know this
uh the current the current line that
they're
using the Zionist are saying that the
Palestinians are amorites you must
remember what Amal has done to you says
our Holy Bible and we do remember and we
are fighting our brave troops and
combatants who are now in Gaza or around
Gaza and in all other regions in
Israel are joining this chain of Jewish
Heroes a chain that has started 3,000
years ago from Joshua Ben until the
of 1948 the please let us know because
now he's
referencing the Bible the person that
you describe is soulless you know Sharky
this person that like can just
exterminate uh two million people and go
have a turkey sandwich two have a turkey
sandwich now he's actually now
referencing the Bible and this is going
over many people's heads many Christians
heads also but he's referencing the
Bible and he's connecting the
Palestinians is that so to the
amalekites what does that mean it it's
not going over the heads of a lot of
Christians that's what scares me because
the propaganda that we're getting here
now
is Netanyahu has declared the
Palestinian people to be the ancient
amalekites the amalekites in the Old
Testament Hebrew Bible were the Eternal
enemies of the Hebrew Jewish
people
so in in the Old Testament script
scripture King David was told to wipe
out the amalekites including their
children Netanyahu is telling the
Israeli soldiers that the Palestinians
are the
amalekites and he he quoted he quoted
the Old Testament scripture from the
book of numbers and he quoted the verse
that says kill the
babies wow so now you have these
Christian Zionist pastors in America
telling their Church
congregations the Jews in Israel are
fighting the
amalekites they're saying this on
Twitter on
Facebook they're saying these are the
amalekites and look what look what you
have to do look what God told the
Hebrews to do to the
amalekites well that was like 4,000
years ago
mhm that's not to today wow and the
Palestinians aren't amalekites they're
Palestinians
and and so Netanyahu is justifying he's
using Old Testament Hebrew scripture to
justify modern
genocide this is uh unbelievable I can't
it is I want to get into this next uh
clip with the governor and get your
reaction to this okay uh I don't think
it's a question of manipulating America
I think it's you you have the American
people by and large have affinity for
Israel uh part largely I think more from
in in our Christian Community than
anything just based on on the history of
the judeo-christian tradition and how
it's informed this country so I think it
is unique in terms of the the Affinity
that our country has for Israel because
of the of the Biblical history and
people's uh adherence to the
judeo-christian tradition yeah earlier
today uh so I want to stick with those
Affinity towards Israel Biblical history
Jud judeo you hear us a lot the judeo
Christian history and this is why the
support is coming what you what is your
reaction to that well this term
judeo-christian um values I never heard
it until about 20 years ago 20 years ago
so this was a phrase that was dropped in
somebody created This this
term propagandas and they dropped it
into the minds of people and you started
hearing it over and over and over our
judeo-christian heritage and a lot of us
were going what what do you mean America
doesn't have a Jewish Christian
Heritage but that was the message
America has a Jewish Christian
Heritage so the took ownership of
America uh I mean that's literally what
they're doing they're saying hey uh the
Zionist yes the Zionist the Zionist were
claiming ownership of the founding of
America this country has a
judeo-christian
Heritage well it
doesn't but it's it's a propaganda
technique and now it's it's said so
often that nobody questions it it's just
accept
it and when guys like me say it's hey
that that's
propaganda then we're we're crit I'm
criticized as though I don't know what
I'm talking about but I I'll tell you
Eddie I've got a long
memory and I can remember a lot of
things and I can remember the way things
were
before and I I know when certain
propaganda messages were dropped into
the
society but most people don't most
people don't have a long memory let me
get into this uh next clip here cultures
in and that's I think what's happened
there's no go zones in France and in and
in Britain and some of these places
that's not a recipe for Success so I
think Europe's going to have a very
difficult time with these tensions
bubbling up I think we have the ability
to still be smart about what we're doing
here in the United States um and avoid
some of what what they've walked
themselves into I I just I just hope and
and pray that this thing doesn't get
ugly I know you got three kids I got
four we uh uh you know when you think
from your kids perspective it's a little
bit concerning when you're seeing this
is not calming down it's getting worse
and it's like at a bar it's like what'
you say what you say and everybody's
like did you see what he said and it's
just getting more and more and more
heated and we got to kind of figure out
bring it
down I like what uh Patrick B David was
saying we got to figure out a way to
calm it down and I want to address this
no-o zones in uh in I think he said
France and I think this is this is
incorrect what the governor is with all
due respect uh this is not true true
these no-go zones and Muslims would love
I mean I mean you can probably when
you're in Jordan and whatnot they paint
this picture as Muslims are barbarians
you go over there gonna cut your head
off I mean they'd love for you to come
in any neighborhood come and eat with us
sit with us you know you you've
experienced that right I think the
zantis needs to go to Jordan or wherever
you were and to see it for himself I
mean so when they say there's no go
zones and all this other nonsense but
you do have unfortunately you do have
and that's you know the situation with
the apartheid now you do have IDF
soldiers who come out and they'll
testify this is not you know M we're not
making this up you have streets there
that are used specifically for Zionist
for people who follow not Moses's
teachings but Theodor Herzel you know
and you cannot go you cannot go down
these streets and you have two sets of
laws you know one for people who's who
zionists and uh the right of return only
for certain people this is Injustice I'm
Israeli Jewish American as well my
partner is Palestinian and I can do
things that he can't do um I can travel
quite freely and even though his mother
is a refugee from what is now Israel he
can't pass areas that are off limits to
Palestinians I have um excellent rights
I have health there are cities in Israel
being built for Jews only and also in
the West Bank settlements being built
for Israeli Jews only while Palestinians
are hemmed in unable to build cities and
their homes are being demolished for
lack of permits that are almost
impossible to get um the Israeli
authorities are engaging in forcable
transfer where they remove Palestinian
communities in the West Bank to make
room for settlements all of these are
part of the root causes of the violence
there's terrible abuses going on you
just have to listen to what people on
the ground are telling you and adjust
accordingly this is what Nelsa Mandela
also was against and Jimmy Carter called
this apartheid state Etc so um how would
you respond uh to this I like what
Patrick said about we got to have level
heads we got to calm this thing
down well I would say I agree but the
ruling class of America is deliberately
doing the
opposite they need the tension they need
the anger they need the
division the the ruling class of America
is not trying to calm things down
they're trying to Jack things up they're
trying to get people angry at each other
they want us fighting at each other
Eddie they don't want you and me to do
what we're doing right
now having a a civilized conversation
between two gentlemen they don't want it
they want us yelling at each other look
at the news shows look at how they do
everything is shouting yelling
everything that they've done to America
in the last 20 years has been to divide
us make us angry make us afraid afraid
they're doing it to the whole world
yesterday uh it may have been on Monday
Vladimir Putin uh gave a speech in
Russia and he said the globalists I
don't know what I think he said the the
rulers of the
West need chaos to stay in
power and that they're doing it to the
whole
world I mean everywhere they're setting
the world on fire
they did it with
Ukraine they have it now happening in
the Middle East the next spot will be
Asia they need the world to be in chaos
they need people to be fighting each
other and so we we defeat them by doing
the opposite of what they
want don't let them make you angry don't
let them make you fear other people
do the opposite of what they're
programming you and me to do certain
things to think a certain way to talk a
certain way don't give into
it you you mentioned the
hospitality of the Arabic people I I've
I I was amazed in my trips to Jordan
strangers would invite me to their home
for
dinner I'd start a conversation and they
would say please please come over to my
dinner oh come over to my house for
dinner let's let's continue this
conversation wonderful people but you
know the first time I went to a
Palestinian area was 2018 I went into uh
Bethlehem I had been in St Petersburg
Russia attending a conference and
decided at the last minute to fly to to
Tel Aviv and attend the Christ at the
checkpoint conference in Bethlehem which
is held by a group of Palestinian
Christians trying to get American
Christians to understand what's
happening in
Palestine and Eddie when I told friends
that I was going to um the West Bank I
had so many well-meaning people who
cared about me and they said now Rick
you got to you got to think about this
you're going over there and they're
they're going to try to behead
you wow I'm not and they were sincere
they were really afraid they thought I'm
going my life was in
danger and when I came back and said no
they were
wonderful they were awesome I I've got
new friends and everywhere I went I was
treated kindly they were like that can't
be true these were the true these were
the Palestinians there yes the
Palestinians in the in the in Bethlehem
in the West Bank they treated me with
such kindness I didn't ask are you a
Christian are you a Muslim I didn't they
just were people they're just people I
just accept people for being people all
right I don't want to put a label on
anybody I just want to accept people for
being
people but the ruling class of America
wants us to Mark everybody put a label
on them fight with them argue with them
divide
conquer don't communicate separate why
because they stay ower when we're
divided mhm and when we refuse to be
angry with others when we refuse to hate
when we refuse to be afraid they lose
power have you heard of um upand Coming
he's been around for a while now and
he's he's the host of a Christian
conservative talk show radio his name is
Charlie Kirk sure have you met him do
you know him no I know who he is but I
don't know him would you uh if um
because I've been in contact with him
now I heard him talking about how he
wanted to work together with Muslims and
I get really elated when I hear this
Christians you know like yourself who
you know want to uh unify on a common
good because you have a lot of with the
alphabet movement and other things you
know the sexual sexualization of the
children and so many things that were
going on and he he he was at that moment
um he was on a pbd podcast and same
thing with Patrick mavid he's a he's a
Christian he brought he brought us out
there and I met him very nice man and he
was talking about this and then all of a
sudden this broke out and it's kind of
his tone changed and whatnot and I was
like you know what he needs someone like
you a mentor you know someone would you
would you be willing to Mentor someone
like Charlie I mean you know someone
who's wise who has a lot of experience
you know hopefully this gets to Charlie
and you know Charlie Kirk I think he's
in Florida also ABS absolutely what
advice would you have for Charlie
someone like Charlie Kirk and the like
because you had you had people don't
understand how I was just when I was in
uh in Chicago this was just a few weeks
ago a couple weeks ago we had a young
boy six years old stabbed 26 times and
then when they asked his wife uh what
happened to him she said he had been
listening to this was his tenant now the
uh the Muslim family Palestinian he
built them a treehouse and everything so
this is the Power of Words you know when
you can you can really put things out
there that can soften hearts or Harden
hearts and make people go into rage
people are already like you know at the
so anyways they said that he had been
listening to conservative talk radio the
suspect's wife told detectives he
listened to conservative talk radio and
thought the mother and son would have
people over to attack them he apparently
had been listening to conservative radio
for some time Joe listens to
conservative talk radio on a regular
basis and has been heavily interested in
the events that have recently occurred
in Israel she also said he was concerned
about the national day of jihad and
wanted Shaheen and her son to move out
is he listening to some of these people
who are you know pushing people to the
edge and we don't want we don't want
Charlie to go down their ride or others
so what advice would you have for people
like this you're talking about you're
talking about the little H six-year-old
boy that was stabbed to death you know
about that do you yes uh by his by the
landlord the man house yes yes yes so he
was probably listening to Shan Hannity
and people like that who are and Mark
Levin and others who are whipping up
this anger uh Glenn Beck other people um
they're they're making people angry and
afraid I would say to Charlie to pursue
truth and be
prepared
that there may be attempts to cut off
his
money that's what I would say um but if
you do if you do right if your if your
motive is right right it doesn't matter
if wealthy people cut off the
money um I've had so many threats I've
been doing this Eddie for 25
years I've had so many threats I've had
death threats I've had all kinds of
threats I you know people have
threatened to shut me down uh silence me
kill me you know I just keep going I I
just keep going and it doesn't I'm not
going to say it doesn't bother me I take
these threats seriously um and I've lost
let me tell you Eddie I have since I
came out as Pro
Palestinian I've lost so many
friends I've lost
donors I've lost business
partners when I say Partners I mean
vendors MH
um the zionists work around the clock to
hurt
me they call they call companies that
are doing business with me and they
threaten them
wow um I've lost almost all of my
friends among Christian churches and
pastors they don't want to talk to
me
um because they they can't understand
how could you be against Israel and for
the
Palestinians and I tell them you you you
misunderstand who and what Israel is you
are stealing my house and if I don't
steal it someone else is going to steal
it no no one no
one is allowed to steal it so if you're
a Palestinian and you live in Gaza
you're just you're just stuck you're
stuck forever and that's why these
people are like people from America
they're like why you know that's why you
have this Mantra like oh they want to
die they raised their kids to be suicide
bombers no when you're in you are born
dead you don't have a life so that's why
these people are giving up their lives
to send a message to us that's why
they're doing this that's the only
reason they're doing this is to send a
message to us help us that's all they
can do and I found out that it wasn't
exactly like that that in order to make
this Jewish dream a reality we had to
visit a nightmare on the local
population and there's no way you could
have ever created a a Jewish state
without uh oppressing and ex expelling
the local population Jewish Israeli
historians has shown without a doubt
that the explosion of the Palestinians
was persistent it was pervasive it was
cruel it was
murderous and with deliberate attempt
so that's what's called the Naka in
Arabic the disaster or the catastrophe
there's a law that you cannot deny the
Holocaust but in Israel you're not
allowed to mention the NBA even though
it was at the very basis of the
foundation of the state Israel is not a
nation ancient Israel in the Old
Testament and there are there are some
there are some uh Orthodox Jews who
would agree with me they will tell you
that ancient Israel was not a political
state it was a people a nation a nation
that obeyed God loved God and obeyed
God that's
Israel and so I tell people that thing
over there in Palestine is not Israel
it's fake it's made up it's
man-made and it's built on
blood I know about Aron and Lehi and
Hagan I know what they did I know
about
the massacres in the
40s I learned this on my
own and when you try to tell Christians
today about it they they can't believe
it because it's it's like you're making
this up no I'm not making up let me show
you the
facts and one by one we're we're winning
we're showing people the facts and one
by one they're coming but Charlie Kirk I
would encourage him to pursue truth and
be prepared to suffer the consequences
for pursuing truth truth is free but it
comes with a
price the truth itself is free but you
pay a price for getting
it that's great advice hopefully you'll
take it uh we got a few more minutes um
yeah I myself I mean they played this
with this term anti-semitic I mean this
is a ridiculous I'm not anti-semitic you
you you mentioned having to Jewish
neighbors friends down there in uh your
neighborhood and you had great
relationships with and they you know
I've had rabis on the program till
Zionism came about Jews flourished as as
distinctly religious Jewish communities
and they weren't Massac on the contrary
they went to these Arab and Muslim lands
to escape persecution uh from the
Crusades from the Inquisition and from
many other trials and tribulations and
the um and even World War II uh the Arab
and Muslim lands opened their hearts
open their lands and uh provided a safe
haven and a gracious Hospitality for the
Jewish people clearly they we we have
different religion and yet uh we were we
were accepted in these Muslim and Arabs
we believe in one God and we were
accepted we have different ways of
serving God and but yet as I we were
respected and even the Muslim religion
requires of that of of the uh the Muslim
people to to provide protection and
hospitality and they did uh carry that
out that's clear nobody could refute
this I had also um Israelis people who
are also against this Theodor herzo
movement of Zionism and it it showed how
at the time you were you you gave a
great example when we started off with
the program Jerusalem when um you had
Salah Ubi and you had Jews and Christian
Muslims living together in peace and uh
we're this is what we're we're striving
for and yes I instead of mentioning my
my next uh clip I had a Christian on uh
some time ago and he was somebody also
he was uh a script writer for the louder
for crowter show he actually uh was with
Tommy Robinson writing his theme song he
was somebody who hated Muslims and and
he was very famous uh comedian actor and
this is really short clip I want to just
show you because it goes into my next
question because there's a lot of lot of
hate out there and go ahead
yeah there's a lot of programming that
I've realized has happened in America of
the anti-muslim programming because we
all know there's Pharisees in every
religion there's some bad Muslims some
bad Christians and bad Jews everything
but that whole um you know just the
boogeyman that you're referring to and I
started realizing that I had more in
common with some of these Muslims than I
did a lot of these um uh converged
Christians Christian and name only you
know they're they're blaspheming they're
saying Eve was transgender and you know
all this insane stuff they have a a
rainbow flag in front you know promoting
sodomy and stuff and I'm like well that
Muslim fam is just having a bunch of
kids and they seem like they uh are very
honest people I'm like what is going on
because I used to think that Muslims
were the Boogeyman and there are some
that are Muslim and name only as we all
know but it's not something that really
changed my perspective was when a Muslim
friend of mine I heard him say Jesus
peace be upon him and I had always
thought that you guys hated Jesus you
know and that was and that blew my mind
because I listen to Ben Shapiro on Joe
Rogan talk about how Jesus Christ was um
a common criminal and was killed for
rebelling against Rome which is this
insane statement and then my Muslim
friend would say Jesus peace be upon him
and I was like huh that kind of made it
through the programming and that goes
into to my question do you get offended
when we say Jesus peace be upon him that
you know when we you know when I tell
you I proudly I'm very proud and excited
to say I love Jesus obviously we can get
the elephant out of the room you know
the difference we don't believe he's uh
God okay we can we can agree to disagree
on something but I mean we love him we
love his Blessed Mother and I've tried
to I've tried to tell Christians Muslims
love and respect
Jesus not as a Son of God as we do but
they love and respect him but Jews will
spit on the ground when you say his name
that is The Godly thing to do we respect
one another The Godly thing to do is to
kill you The Godly thing is to kill me
that's right that's what the Torah says
the Torah says to kill us the Torah says
that Idol people who worship Idol such
as yourself when there is a
Sanhedrin to kill us yes okay that's
what the Torah say so we know how the
Jewish people feel about Christians yes
that you discriminate against Christians
Christians are Idol discriminate against
says that Christianity is idol
worship
you
that's you I'm a Jewish and I'm the
blessed one you are the curse you
understand why are you why are you
defending the people that will spit when
you say Jesus and then hating the people
who say I love Jesus it doesn't make
sense to me that's such a strange
relationship uh in this video also he
talks about Ben Shapiro I don't know if
you've heard of him Ben Shapiro I call
him I call him blaspheming Ben you know
why because I went after him a couple
years ago I'm the only Christian that
that went after him publicly because he
said that Jesus was a criminal a
revolutionary who deserved to be
crucified wow and I went after him and I
called him a blasphemer and now whenever
I talk about him I always call him
blaspheming Ben but do you know do you
know uh somebody who used to work at
breit Bart news which was started by uh
Netanyahu it was wow I didn't know that
oh yes yes uh Andrew Breitbart worked
closely with Netanyahu to start
Breitbart News but a a man who worked at
Breitbart
News said recently that when he worked
at Breitbart he
saw Israeli mad agents
delivering information to Ben Shapiro to
put out in his
videos
out of this world so Shapiro
is whether he's paid or not paid he he
is an Israeli
intelligence asset is an
operative there's one thing I wantan to
I want to add because I don't if you got
a close I I'll be quiet no go ahead no
no no keep going keep going yeah I want
to just respect your time go ahead well
okay it's your it's your show I don't
want to take over your keep going no no
keep going I'm really enjoying talking
with you okay you mentioned earlier
anti-Semitism what is
anti-Semitism I refuse to use the word
anymore once I figured it out I don't
say it anymore is dissent expressed in
the United States against policies of
the Israeli government um uh people here
are called anti-semitic what is your
response to that as an Israeli Jew well
it's a trick we always use it when from
Europe somebody's criticizing Israel
then we bring up the Holocaust when in
this country people are criticizing in
Israel then there are anti-semitic and
the organization is strong and has a lot
of money and the the ties between Israel
and the American EST Jewish
establishment are very strong and they
are strong in this country as you know
they have power which it's okay they are
talented people and they have power
money and media and other things and
their attitude is Israel my country
right or wrong the
identification and they are not ready to
hear
criticism so if you ask the average
person they would say well anti-Semitism
is the hatred of
Jews well let me ask you if it's
anti- anti-Semitism that means that
there's
a PR semitism and if there's a PR
semitism there is a semitism so
Eddie what is a
Semite a Semite is somebody from this
area um is there is there is there a
race of
semites is there a
race no is there isn't that's right
there's no race of people called
semites you know what you know what
unpackage that so that's semites you
think of people who are uh in this
geographical location
actually the the the precise definition
is semites are people who speak citic
languages yeah there you go from this
area who speak the spefic language so an
Arabic Arabic is Arabic is Semitic an
Arab could be a is a Semite you know
it's a anyone from this area Palestinian
is a Semite correct yes so yeah Arabic
is a citic language there's
approximately 30 citic languages so if
when they call me
anti-semitic does that mean I hate
people that speak Semitic
languages see it's a propaganda
term so we shouldn't we shouldn't
even participate in it it's a propaganda
term that was
created to confuse people there's no
such thing as a citic race there are
citic languages and Arabic is one of
Aramaic is a Semitic language there are
30 plus languages that are called
Semitic but there's no such thing as a
citic race of people but they want you
to believe that if they call you
anti-semitic that you're against a race
of people well bring me out a Semite
show me a
Semite I like to see one because they
can't produce
it but challenge on it and they'll shut
up because they know you figured it out
I don't know if you know that that
modern Hebrew is a reconstructed
language the the
zionists it's been so many thousands of
years since anybody spoke Hebrew that
nobody nobody in the modern day knew
what it sounded like they had the
writings they knew what it looked like
but they didn't know what it sounded
like so the Zionist
reconstructed the language and made it
up I mean for all we know they're
speaking
Klingon they don't know these people
that are speaking Hebrew have no idea if
that's
Hebrew they don't know they made it up
the state of Israel is made up it's a
made up you've got
European white Caucasian
Europeans who practiced
Judaism who moved to Palestine and
displaced the indigenous native
Palestinian
people the Israelis are white European
colonizers now they practice
Judaism but their race is not they're
not from look at their skin color Eddie
are do they look like an Arab
do they look like a Palestinian do they
look like the people that live in
Palestine they look like white Europeans
MH and the reason
is they are descendants of the
khazarians kesar which was an ancient
European
country and the King converted to
Judaism and he forced the entire country
to offici ially become Jews but they
were not racially Jews they were they
adopted
Judaism khazaria
disappeared but guess what if you if you
had a map of the old khazaria Empire and
you laid it over top a modern map guess
what country is inside of it
Ukraine there is talk there was talk 10
years
ago
that the Israelis would abandon
Palestine and relocate in
Ukraine we've got
zalinski a
zionis how did he become the president
of
Ukraine you've got two Wars right now
being run by
zus and America's financing both of
them is Ukraine being
depopulated are
they are they depopulating
Ukraine to make room for a transplant of
Zionist from Palestine to
Ukraine H when I first had heard this
idea I thought it was so far out it
couldn't be real but now I think it's it
there's a
real high likelihood this is
happening the Zionist cannot survive
this war in the Middle
East they can't survive this now they
may win they may win the war but they
can't survive here's why I'm saying
this for them to win they have to be so
brutal so Savage that the whole world
will see them killing
millions of people including children
the world will turn against
them they will be
hated if they carry out their agenda
they will be
hated around the world they know
it what's happening Eddie is the the
West which is primarily the United
States and Israel are in this war and
they have to win it's not about Gaza
it's not about Hamas it's now about the
domination of
Zionism and if they
lose America becomes a third world
nation and Zionism is put out of
business if they
win all of humanity will become
Palestinians and the world will become a
refugee
camp
it's all or nothing and tell me what uh
in the last uh minute we have what is
your advice now to uh just human beings
in general people whose hearts are open
people who don't want to be spending
what is it like almost $4 billion dollar
a year is this good for America is this
good for any God conscious person
someone who says I believe in God you
know is there any good in this and how
can people make a change you know what
what what can they do well Eddie I if
you're asking me question I have to give
you my Christian answer if you may allow
me my Christian answer is we are moving
quickly to the end of
time and almighty God is going to shut
down this world the first time he did it
was at Noah's flood and he said that
mankind thought about wickedness and
evil all day long is the only thing that
they did was evil and wicked and the
world was filled with bloodshed we're
back to the same
place Jesus said that his return to
Earth would be as it was in the days of
Noah what was going on at the time of
Noah the mankind was wicked the world
was filled with
blood I believe with all my heart that
Jesus Christ is coming back soon you
know we you know we believe all as
Muslims in the second coming of Jesus
peace be upon him did you know that yes
okay yes yeah yes go ahead well you
sorry I believe he's coming back I
believe he's coming back and so every
single person has to have their heart
ready and prepared for that moment some
of us may not get through this
physically we may perish in these wars
you mentioned a figure earlier maybe 200
million or maybe no that maybe it was a
person on one of the podcast shows you
you you you you uh shared um I'm
thinking it's more like a billion people
could die in this
war we don't know who's going to make it
who's going to survive but if your soul
is right with almighty
God that's the only thing that
matters and I am telling people make
sure everything in your life is
right and if you're doing anything wrong
stop it if you have bitterness
unforgiveness towards any people make it
right we are approaching a catastrophe
in the
world and I wrote a book about it called
final
day and it ref it refutes Darby ISM
Scofield ISM it refutes it and it's it's
what's what's the name of that book
final day f i n a l the last day final
day it's on Amazon on final day it
refutes Darby ISM and scoffield ISM M
and uh you know I encourage people to
read it and it will explain to them what
I believe about the last days you think
this you think this would this will
definitely help to eliminate the
programming that's uh affected many
Christians who over the years have been
affected by this uh this movement yes uh
we could
see all right one of two things are
going to happen here I'm going go back
to what I just said either we're going
to witness the end of
Zionism as we know it we're going to
witness the end of Zionism or Zionism is
going to take over the
world including the Muslim
world one one or the other if it's the
second one then it means that Zionism is
what the Bible calls the
Beast the Beast system that rules the
world imagine somebody like
Netanyahu in control of artificial
intelligence crazy yeah Rick uh uh God
bless you thank you very much uh for
I've enjoyed this I enjoyed talking with
you God willing we can do it again next
time uh in person as we say God willing
God bless you thank you so much and
hopefully we could we we could we we
makeing history we could be an example
for others that we could you could see a
Muslim Christian come together we can
talk we can go ahead and share some some
good knowledge together and I I I really
enjoyed it thank you I've been honored
thank you very much you've been a
gracious host and uh when you're in
Florida uh come over and see us i' I'd
love to fellowship with you we'll take
you to dinner and um let's let's let's
uh continue our conversation thank you I
appreciate the invitation thank you sir
peace with you thank you I cannot leave
without giving you a gift if you're not
yet Muslim and you tune in to see what
these Muslims are talking about and you
like a free copy of the Quran go ahead
and visit theen show.com we'll take care
of the postage and everything and get it
delivered to you and if you still have
some questions about Islam call us at 1
662 4752 we'll see you next time until
then peace be with you assalam alaykum